in the name of the Father and of the Son and of the Holy Spirit, Amen.
The reading from the Sinaxadion for June 8th, on which we commemorate the Holy New Martyr
Thelphanus.
This glorious martyr was born in the village of Sapanti, in the region of Kalamata, in
the Peloponnese.
Named Theodore in Holy Baptism, he was sent by his parents to Constantinople as a tailor's
apprentice.
Constantly ill-treated by his employer, he fled, and finding himself in the city.
In the midst of the popular rejoicing and festivities organized to celebrate the circumcision
of the Sultan's son, he denied his Christian faith.
He had himself engaged as one of the children who were being prepared to become palace
janissaries, and for six years he received a complete education in Turkish and Arabic
literature.
Treating theological questions in the course of his studies, he began to experience the burning
remorse of his conscience.
At last he could bear it no more, and invoking the Holy Trinity and the Mother of God he fled.
He traveled to various places, always seeking someone who might show him how to find salvation,
and finally came to know the wise patriarch Gabriel who lived in Venice.
The latter instructed him, confirmed him in the faith, and tonsored him among, under the
name of Thelphanus.
He then showed him that the means of perfect expiation of his sin would lie in returning
to the place of his apostasy, and there publicly confessing his conversion.
Filled with divine zeal, Thelphanus returned without delay to Constantinople, where some
people recognized him, but where he found no opportunity to confess his faith in public.
Moving on to Athens, he presented himself before the judge, after three days of prayer bathed
in tears, and demanded that justice be rendered to him for the faith he had lost during
his youthful aberration.
To his great disappointment, the judge indulgently sent him away.
After trying the same tactic in other places, he presented himself before the judge of Larissa,
who was renowned for his cruelty and severity.
But the latter also sent him away, after ordering that he be given 600 lashes.
The saint suffered his punishment with thanksgiving, but was in no way satisfied.
He traveled to Mount Athos, where some of the holy monks encouraged him in his intention,
and then returned to Constantinople, where he appeared in public, ostentatiously addressing
those he had known.
After having been tested by his confessor, Yothimius, he prepared himself for the ultimate
contest by vigil, prayer, and the receiving of the Holy Mysteries.
He then presented himself before the Sultan's tribunal, where a great number of the magistrates
and officials of the Ottoman administration were to be found.
He first praised the sovereign in a loud, clear voice, and then proceeded to confess his conversion
and demanded that justice be rendered him.
The judge, furious at his audacity, ordered that he be given 700 lashes and thrown into prison,
where he was constantly subjected to the cruelty of his guards.
When, in order to mock him, the latter implored him to perform a miracle in their presence,
the saint prayed for three hours, still as an immobile pillar, and as soon as he pronounced
his amen, an earthquake shook the foundations of the prison, and a light more radiant than
the sun, pierced the darkness, revealing the saint freed from his shackles, his hands
stretched towards heaven, and his face, like that of an angel.
Overcome with terror, the guards fell down before him and asked his forgiveness, and some among
them were converted.
In use of this event reached higher magistrates, the prefect had him brought before him once
more, and tried to win him round by promises.
Thelfanas rejected his arguments as one destroys a spider's web and retorted with an
order inspired by the Holy Spirit.
He was therefore sentenced to die, a bitter death.
His torturers seized him immediately, and cut out two strips of his flesh in the form
of a cross, stretching from his back to his chest.
Then, having hitched him backwards onto a mule, with his hands nailed to the saddle, they
paraded him through the streets of the city, arriving at the scaffold.
They suspended him, naked on iron hooks.
While the crowd threw stones at him and hid him with sticks.
Thelfanas remained unyielding and gave thanks to God for having judged him worthy of obtaining
the end he desired, asking him only to manifest himself by a miracle for the conversion of
the godless onlookers.
As soon as he had completed his prayer, a white bird, like a dove, suddenly appeared and
delighted on the martyr's head, filling him with the divine joy and taking all sense
of pain from him.
Many in the crowd then began to cry, he is truly God, this Christ whom he proclaims.
After three hours, as evening approached, the saint cried out, I thirst.
One of the men present replied, become like us and I shall give you a drink.
But Thelfanas replied, it is for your salvation that I thirst.
As for me, Christ will refresh me with eternal water.
During the night there were great claps of thunder and heavenly light suddenly surrounded
the martyr's body so that the guards were filled with dread.
Many confessed Christ which aroused the hatred of other Turks, who rushing to the port
and arming themselves with sharp instruments began to strike the face and body of the saint.
When they tore out his eyes, Saint Thelfanas gave his soul into God's hands on the eighth
of June in 1588.
But Christians retrieved his body and collected the earth that was stained with his blood,
which worked many miracles and healings.
As for his torturers, some became blind, others became mad and drowned themselves in the sea.
The hands of others became withered, but those who repented and invoked the saint obtained
healing.
Through the prayers of our Holy Father's, O Lord Jesus Christ our God, have mercy on us
and save us.